yeah welcome to this video playing FM
row to run us so Rudy yeah one thing
that that's really cool about them
playing on on Isis is that you really
got such a big variety of players
there's so many players on that you ok
you have you have your your opponent's
that you play against very often but I
never played the sky and this is very
high rated on the five-minute pool close
to 24 okay we've got a tirage French
siraj it started out with the knight c6
variation but I played with Bishop d3 NV
transpose to regular line with them with
the c-5m this is curious okay yeah just
push it back maybe maybe a three
considers to be weakness as possible
yeah maybe he's right okay but first I
can reroute the night maybe I should
have I should have prevented a three
okay I want to go g3 edge for night h2g
for stuff like that Bishop to b5 maybe
okay maybe now is the the moment to push
it back ok Knight e5 be three
yeah black setup is so it's fairly solid
I played similar stuff myself back when
I played the French the only problem was
that I am simply didn't have a good time
a good feel for these positions I lost a
very very very many many games not
because of the quality of the positions
really often but because I just didn't
really am had the right kind of
understanding and feel for the for the
positions okay so he's got nice a nicely
positioned tonight CEO so this may be
really threatening this as possible I
mean on one deform okay maybe here
gettin rid of this of this night
yeah okay surprising I thought you would
just take and play we should be five but
as I told you I'm my feeling for those
positions is limited okay so he keeps
default act hmm but is he really
threatening it's not really i can go
here actually if he takes their I can
play but should be three at the end of
the queen is stripped you cannot take
default what problem is he simply has
not cancelled so I don't have fun a
natural target with the King on the key
on the King side this looks nice I mean
just imagine he would Castle I would
probably win instantly what wow this is
interesting what I just take here and
play but should be three where's your
queen going it has no no square okay
yeah this is helpful I mean act I really
wasn't wasn't so sure how to continue if
they don't think white was worse but I
had didn't have form a clear plan ready
simply because he didn't move the king
yeah I don't know maybe it was around
equal 0 so I blue maybe black was better
I don't know these positions are tricky
we reached some some nice am I mean he
realized some some good goals he on the
on the queenside know if he continues
this is also curious
okay ctrl-d too I want to switch the
Queen over here too 2g4 may be
threatening Knight f6 now Knight f6 yeah
it's a good move Queen g4 ok let's made
next move yeah the other position the
position was interesting right before he
he blundered blundered the Queen here
yeah I mean black can I thought you
would just go Bishop b5 and this
certainly cannot be bad for black
although this would be a bad for black
than the French defense would be would
be ridiculous Queenie too I thought
maybe then he can learn I cannot take if
you consider something like this like
simply doesn't castle I mean he can he
can probably even play King Lear seven
at some point and this this is certainly
fine for black he's got those nice
squares and and I don't have a clear
plan this is Sir this is a problem in
this position actually I would consider
Bishop d2 here trying to relocate the
bishop may be here to just cover the
queenside keep it together and then try
to reroute the night so that I need to I
need to provoke something on the
kingside castling even be nice but he
won't do that the computer is completely
cool i mean it once the computer gives
this Bishop f4 and then castles which
frankly speaking is just crap I mean
even if the computer suggested this trap
you don't need to Castle here black just
helps me with this giving me some
ideas for tech the computer maybe is
able to defend this but for human
castling yes is just just a weird move I
don't have a very clear attacking plan
though this is this is the system this
is true I'd like to I need to go here
and then then segment ok this night
covers all the squares hell maybe
objectively castles is not so bad but
for a human I don't know I wouldn't I
wouldn't do that I would rather play
some some strengthening moves like let's
say here maybe even King b7 the problem
is that if you go King here and look
here then there's Queen age 7 at the end
it's still a complicated position with
luckiest as fine of course yeah thanks
for watching